hey what's up guys I'm kV HD here so CES
is always a pretty all over the place
usually pretty wild show this year I
actually think was better than most
there's a lot of interesting stuff
floating around I walked around on the
show floor for many many hours saw a
bunch of stuff playing cameras at it so
you don't have to this is the best of
what I saw
so a lot of people have asked me what
was the best part was the best thing at
this year's show and to those people
I've been saying the Sony car which I
think was the biggest surprise that no
one saw coming so I'll start there so
Sony had a car in their booth and hot
take I think it looks better than almost
every other electric car or any other
car out there and better than a lot of
the cars on the streets today but before
we get too excited no this is not a car
that they plan on shipping or letting
real people buy and drive at least right
now what they've done here really is put
together a one-off prototype car that's
a demonstration of all the different
technologies Sony makes that they feel
they're kind of already in the
automotive business
so you see Sony does a lot of stuff they
make camera sensors and their sony alpha
cameras so this car has rear facing
cameras instead of rearview mirrors
there is radar and lidar sensors which
are all needed for self-driving computer
systems and the interior that I didn't
get to play with had a massive display
and a UI that also all seemed to work
fairly well which makes sense because
Sony also makes computers and smart
phones too then the rest of the car
stuff like brakes and tires and things
like that they had help from a company
called Magna to build it out and that's
how they ended up with a fully
functioning working car so I asked about
specs and I was told quad motors 0-60 in
4.6 seconds and a top speed of 149 miles
an hour not that these specs actually
matter because you can't actually get
one but I was really most impressed by
the design and that's why I want it to
be so real it had some Tesla and some
Porsche Lions like a nice hybrid between
the two of them the whole thing was this
satin silver so no ugly glossy paint
with fingerprints or anything like that
and it also helps that it was lit really
well so yes only came to CES people were
expecting maybe at PS 5 but they would
be silly to waste a PS 5
announcement at CES so we got a car you
know what might have caused even more
confusion to me though Samsung's new
phones so for the first time they
actually showed in their booth what I
mentioned in the last video the Samsung
Galaxy Note 10.1 Galaxy S 10 light now
since we already have galaxy s 10a I was
confused so I asked the Samsung reps
that were at the booth
are these flagships and their answer was
well no these are light flagships so
take that for what it's worth so these
phones both have a 6.7 inch 1080p flat
OLED displays with the selfie camera cut
out in the top middle they both have
4500 milliamp hour batteries but no
wireless charging and they run a
Snapdragon a 55 in the s10 light and a
similar Exynos 9810 in the note 10 light
and they both have this new rectangular
camera bump on the back that we're
expecting as a design in the new
flagships in a couple weeks although the
camera situations are slightly different
on each of them the note 10 light has 3
12 megapixel cameras a wide a 2x
telephoto and an ultra wide simple
enough but then the s10 light has a 48
megapixel main camera with super steady
shot video then a 12 megapixel ultra
wide and a 5 megapixel macro camera and
then note 10 light also adds the stylus
of course and a headphone jack but it's
the only one not coming to the United
States so why exactly do these phones
now exist like I guess you could ask
that about a lot of things that's CES
but to me it's confusing because Samsung
already has some pretty great mid-range
phones in their lineup like the a 51 and
the a 71 but either way these will slot
in around I've been told the $650 range
and they'll tide us over until we do get
that Galaxy S 20 and galaxy fold to then
oneplus showed a concept phone at CES
the oneplus concept one with
electrochromatic tinting glass on the
back of the phone that can both hide the
ugly camera bumps of the future and act
as nd neutral density filters for photos
and videos I did an entire separate
video on this concept phone so if you
want to check that out link right below
that like button it's a good one and
they
brought to CES an entire piano made of 1
+ 70 pros all smartphones
[Music]
okay then I saw not just one but two
different rotating TVs on the show floor
at CES this year one from TCL with these
rounded corners to match a typical
smartphone display and one from Samsung
called the Samsung Cerro basically the
idea here is we do so much streaming and
content viewing from our smartphone that
we might as well have our TVs rotate
between portrait and landscape to
appropriately frame the content we're
watching without black bars depending on
your smartphone orientation which I
guess makes sense or we could just stop
shooting so much vertical video anyway I
also saw I stopped by the Bosch booth
quickly where also it was treated to a
pretty interesting surprise which was an
LED activated Sun Visor for a car
basically this entire rig is just a
camera somewhere in the front of a car
doing face tracking and then the clear
panel in front of your face will block
out the Sun but still leave other areas
you need to see like the road and the
traffic light you're stopped at things
like that and it worked pretty well not
perfectly but it kept my face and eyes
shaded tracked which was cool and then I
could see other things
okay cars so there were a lot of cars
just like there are at every CES and
there was one pretty wild Mercedes one
that I wanted to see but I didn't but
that was apparently out in the streets
and driving around it didn't even really
look street-legal or real I fully didn't
expect this to be a real car but I did
see two real electric cars that I think
coming up are gonna be while probably
pretty interesting autofocus episodes so
the Ford Mustang Mach II is one of them
so the electric SUV Mustang it was there
and I gotta say I'm not a Mustang person
obviously but this one here in the blue
did look better in person than a lot of
the Mackey's I've seen in videos and
photos it's a pretty normal size like a
Honda CRV type of crossover size and it
has a lot of cameras all over the place
a lot of sensors but overall looks
prefinished look pretty complete here
I'm rooting for it though I'm glad for
it is making this move now right now
it's scheduled for 2021 so there is some
waiting to do and it'll probably be at
CES again next year before it even comes
out but yeah the forward Mustang
Mach II was there and then so was the
rivey n' r1t pickup truck also in blue
and I was also sitting in their booth
looking pretty complete as well and this
one's scheduled to come out this year
2020 and I was told by them they want to
start hitting the road with these around
summer and delivering them to buyers by
this winter so this is another one of
the more promising electric cars
that's definitely coming out then there
were a lot of robots at CES but still
again none of them were quite as cool as
the omron ping-pong playing robot that I
got to rematch with this year so this
year the giant ping pong instruction
robot which is just a combination of on
Ron's technologies again used as a
showcase but not actually for sale this
one will not just keep track of how well
you're hitting the ball back to the
robot but also how your emotions
factored in so there's new cameras and
things keeping track of how much you
smile versus how much you frown and it's
sort of trying to sense if I get
frustrated or unhappy with something and
it'll do that less but still help me
work on my game which I thought was
hilarious and it was all shown on the
display live as we were playing really
fun stuff and then some other little
things razor had a tomahawk mini PC
where thanks to an Intel nook compute
unit and a special case and motherboard
set up and tiny power supply the entire
computer is really small it's the size
of basically a large external GPU
enclosure you could fit the whole thing
in a shoebox if you wanted to
fascinating but I don't see that being
super useful to me it's still cool to
see and then I tried a racing simulator
in the Razer booth that was essentially
fully suspended off the ground with
realistic steering wheel paddle shifters
a gas on a brake in a clutch pedal and
dual projectors for full immersion and
the most immersive part for me was the
seat belt pulling against my chest when
I slammed against the brakes which was
wild and then I'll say it looks like
Samsung did finally make a TV with no
bezels and I don't just mean thin bezels
I mean literally seems like this is just
basically a hundred percent screen to
body ratio no idea if they're actually
going to be able to ship this one or not
but if they do I'm here for it
I really want it so overall CES
takeaways for me this year were number
one 4k is
still on the rise and it's not
everywhere yet and 8k is now that new
stretch I will say electric cars are
coming and they're coming up quick and
you can put Alexa in pretty much
anything CES is still fun and it's still
home to all the craziest wildest gadgets
in the world for a week in Las Vegas and
I'm glad we made it out here hopefully
enjoy the video thanks for watching and
I'll catch you guys in the next one pace
[Music]